>> Sean: WE HAVE COVERED ON
THIS PROGRAM NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
FAR LEFT IDEOLOGIES INFILTRATING
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM FROM
GRADE SCHOOL INTO COLLEGE
GETTING SO BAD THAT EVEN THOSE
WHO HAVE FLED FROM TOTALITARIAN
REGIMES SEEKING FREEDOM IN
AMERICA IN SEARCH OF FREEDOM OF
THOUGHT TAKING NOTICE.
AN ACTUAL DEFECTOR FROM
NORTH KOREA WHO ATTENDED THE
IVY LEAGUE INSTITUTION KNOWN AS
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY IS SPEAKING
OUT TELLING FOXNews.com THAT
CLIMATE INSIDE COLUMBIA REMINDS
HER OF NORTH KOREA LIGHTING
SEEMS LIKE ANTI-WESTERN
SENTIMENT, COLLECTIVE GUILT,
SUFFOCATING POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS FOR EXAMPLE DURING
ORIENTATION SHE SAID SHE WAS
SCOLDED FOR SAYING THAT SHE
ENJOYED THE WORKS OF ACCLAIMED
AUTHOR JANE AUSTEN AND WAS TOLD
THE BOOKS ARE RACIST ALONG WITH
BEING SUBJECTED TO WHAT SHE SAW
AS NONSTOP ANTI-AMERICAN
PROPAGANDA.
HERE TO TELL HER STORY IS
NORTH KOREA DEFECTOR ALONG WITH
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR
MIKE HUCKABEE.
I READ THIS STORY, YOU GREW UP
AND HOW MANY YEARS -- YOU WERE
IN NORTH KOREA 20 YEARS AND YOU
THINK THE INDOCTRINATION IN THE
UNITED STATES AT HER IVY LEAGUE
INSTITUTION COLUMBIA IS AS BAD
OR WORSE AS THE PROPAGANDA
ANTI-AMERICAN HATE THAT YOU
HEARD IN NORTH KOREA?
>> WHEN I WAS IN NORTH KOREA,
THE FIRST THING THAT I LEARNED
WAS AMERICANS WERE THIS PROBLEM
SAYING HOW MANY AMERICAN AND AS
A CHILD IN NORTH KOREA, YOU HAVE
TO.
AND I SAID I LOVE THIS COUNTRY,
THIS IS SUCH A LOVABLE COUNTRY.
I'VE NEVER BEEN ACCEPTED IN THIS
COUNTRY AND COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY,
LITERALLY EVERY PROFESSOR WAS
SAYING THE PROBLEMS THAT WE HAVE
IN TODAY'S WORLD IS BECAUSE OF
WHITE MEN.
ASIA, THAT'S HOW THEY MESS UP
EVERYTHING AND THEY ARE THE ONES
THAT I COULDN'T BELIEVE I WAS
SITTING IN NORTH KOREA'S
CLASSROOM IN AMERICA, I COULDN'T
BELIEVE MY PEOPLE WERE HATING
THEIR OWN PEOPLE THAT MUCH.
>> Sean: WHAT IS YOUR OVERALL
THOUGHT WHEN YOU LOOK AT AMERICA
TODAY AND YOU COMPARE IT WITH
YOUR LIFE EXPERIENCE WHICH HAS
BEEN HORRIFIC, SOLD INTO SLAVERY
AT ONE POINT IN YOUR LIFE, YOU
ARE EXPECTING THIS TO BE THE
LAND OF THE FREE IN THE HOME OF
THE BRAVE AND THE LAND OF
FREEDOM AND YOU GET THE EXACT
SAME PROPAGANDA HERE.
>> IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
I WAS SOLD AS A AND I CROSSED
THE DESERT TO BE FREE AND NOW I
THOUGHT I LIVE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE I CAN SAY WERE I BELIEVE
AND HAVE MY FREEDOM TO THINK.
I HAVE TO CONSTANTLY CENSOR MY
SPEECH BECAUSE COLUMBIA TOLD US
WE CAN'T TALK ABOUT AND I AM SO
CONCERNED IF AMERICA IS NOT
FREE, THAT'S WHY IT'S REALLY
ALARMING TO ME.
>> Sean: SOMETIMES WHEN YOU
WERE IN THE MIDDLE OF WHAT I
CALL INCREMENTALISM'S
STEP-BY-STEP, WE NOW KNOW WHAT
CANCEL CULTURE IS, WE KNOW WHAT
IS POLITICALLY INCORRECT AND
THEN TO HEAR THIS DOES IT REALLY
ME BUT HEARING IT STILL SHOCKS
ME IF THAT MAKES ANY SENSE.
>> I'LL TELL YOU WHAT WOULD MAKE
A LOT OF SENSE.
WHY DON'T WE GET HER A TOUR BUS
AND WE WILL PAY FOR IT, YOU AND
ME AND WE WILL SEND HER TO EVERY
COLLEGE CAMPUS IN AMERICA AND
LET THIS REMARKABLE YOUNG WOMAN
SPEAK AND TELL HER STORY AND LET
PEOPLE KNOW I'M GIVING AWAY
SOMETHING THEY CAN NEVER GET
BACK AND I'M SO PROUD OF HER.
YOU HAVE NO IDEA.
HOW GRATEFUL I AM FOR THE
COURAGE AND THE CLARITY OF HER
STORY AND I JUST WANT TO TELL
HER THERE ARE A LOT OF US WHO
LOVE AMERICA, WHO STILL BELIEVE
IN FREEDOM AND WE BELIEVE IN YOU
AND WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT YOU ARE
HERE IN YOUR MESSAGE IS ONE THAT
I HOPE EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN
WILL HEAR.
I KNOW SOME OF THEM WON'T, THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WERE TAUGHT TO
BELIEVE, THEY PROBABLY WON'T
CARE BUT ALL OF US ARE NOT LIKE
THAT, WE REALLY AREN'T.
>> Sean: YOU SHOULD READ SOME
OF MIKE'S BOOKS ABOUT SOUTHERN
SAYINGS.
REMEMBER THIS SPEECH?
I BELIEVE IF MY MEMORY SERVES ME
RIGHT, HERE IS A GUY WHO FORMER
SOVIET UNION SAYING YOU'RE
GETTING BAD HERE TOO AND HERE'S
WHAT YOU ARE DOING WRONG.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER THIS TRIP,
THIS BUS TRIP THAT
GOVERNOR HUCKABEE IS TALKING
ABOUT, CONSIDER GOING TO COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ALTHOUGH I HAVE TO WARN
YOU, YOU WOULD PROBABLY BE
PROTESTED AND THEY WOULD TRY TO
CANCEL YOU WHEN SHUT YOU DOWN
BECAUSE THAT HAPPENS AS A
CONSERVATIVE I CAN TELL YOU
EVERY CONSERVATIVE I KNOW LIVE
THROUGH THAT EXPERIENCE.
>> I HAVE BEEN ON THE KILLING
LIST OF PEOPLE FOR MANY YEARS
BECAUSE I SPOKE OUT AND BUY
ORIGINAL FAMILY GOT PUNISHED BUT
NOW IRONICALLY ENOUGH, SO MANY
MARXISTS AND COMMUNISTS NOW ARE
SENDING ME DEATH THREATS AND IS
IT SUCH AN IRONY THAT I DON'T
EVEN KNOW HOW TO RESPOND THAT
THIS IS A WAR THAT AGAIN
SOCIALISM AND COMMUNISM, THE
FACT THAT I COME FROM
NORTH KOREA AND SAY NORTH KOREA
BEGAN AS AN EQUAL SOCIETY AND
NOW THE REGIME'S DIFFERENT
CLASSES BASED ON YOUR STATUS,
BASED ON WHAT YOUR GRANDFATHER
DID AND WHEN I WENT TO COLUMBIA,
THEY SAID YOU MUST BE GUILTY.
YOU AUTHORIZE THIS BECAUSE YOU
WERE WHITE.
YOU DON'T CHOOSE YOUR ANCESTORS,
YOU DON'T CHOOSE YOUR RACE AND
PEOPLE SHOULDN'T BE PUNISHED IN
THE SAME THING IS HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW.
>> Sean: YOUR TESTIMONY IS
POWERFUL.
THE BIBLE SAYS T